thank you
good evening everybody and welcome to
this District planning committee held on
Tuesday the 11th of July 2023.
my name is councilor Kevin Lagan and I
am the chairman of this committee and
I'm joined in the chamber this evening
by Officer Mr Michael Johnson
members and all present we're streaming
this meeting live as well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are given your consent to being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
could I ask members to avoid approaching
the top tables this could create
interference with the cameras and the
live stream equipment
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct usual microphones therefore can
I ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn on your microphone and
turn it off when finished
please reference a page or a paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible please
a gender item number two apologies for
absence committee Clark could I have
apologies for absence please
Morgan Morley Neil Pratt traughnessy as
a signal
sure yeah thank you very much indeed we
moved to agenda item three which is
minutes of the last meeting is
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 14th of June 2023
found on pages 7 to 16 are approved as a
true and accurate record I propose this
do I have a second bit for the motion
councilor Spence Lee councilor Paula
Spencer thank you does any member wish
to raise any points of accuracy
so we'll agree that by Ascent members
thank you very much indeed
item number four which is Declarations
of interest to disclose the existence
and nature of any disclosable pecuniar
interests other registerable interests
and non-registerable interests relating
to items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph 9 and
appendix B of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
knees arise throughout the meeting
members do I have any declarations
so there are no declarations registered
thank you
gender item five has been deferred upon
advice of the monitoring officer and the
planning department so we will move on
to agenda item six
which is reference number two three
slash zero zero two two six slash r e s
m which is land at Broad Street Green
Road and Langford Road and maypole Road
Great Tottenham Essex which is found in
your agenda pack on pages 27 to 70. we
have a public participant Mr Carl
glossop who's an agent for the applicant
and I'll ask Mr glossop to attend the
table and speak after the officer's
report I believe Mr Johnson there's a
verbal update on this item
thank you chairman uh the verbal update
uh relates to consultations
um received since the publication of the
agenda
um and I set out in the report where it
said that there would be an update uh so
uh from waste there's been no response
Police Service is ecology they have no
objection subject to conditions relating
to soft Landscaping retention and
protection of existing Hedges and shrubs
tree protection and service runs all
with details to be submitted for
approval
Utility Services we don't have any
responsible utility services but um but
that's not uncommon
um but um
you know the developers required under
mandatory regulations in terms of works
up with impact on the nature and
capacity of existing infrastructure and
work with the utility companies
accordingly thank you chairman thank you
Mr Johnson
um back to you Mr Johnson to present the
report please
the presentation I should say thank you
thank you chairman
right so this application is for the
reserve matters for phase three
comprising parcel 4 for 234 dwellings
following outline approval on appeal in
2019 for approximately 1 100 dwellings
the reserve matters comprise access
appearance Landscaping layout and scale
and the development is one of several
Parcels of residential development
and as obviously as members can see
there's a corresponding application
comprising three parcels
and it follows other previous Parcels
which have been approved by by this
committee that has been Parcels one and
two and 10 11 and 12.
so I'll just take you through the
slides
so again there's a location plan
this is the application
site and where it fits in within the
overall
haybridge Gardens suburb development
site
this is a proposed layout plan
again we can just see the houses
obviously laid out
um
around a courtyard type of development
and
the approach that
go into the various Parcels sort of in a
traditional way but I think the key
thing to sort of draw out here is where
these
um uh various Parcels Link in with the
wider infrastructure
um so we can see the various exit points
where they where they do link into the
various infrastructure to enable
obviously the free flow of movement into
and out of the various plots
uh story Heights if you have the key
here uh single story two-story three two
and a half story and three stories and
how did
plotted around the site
the affordable housing we can see this
is the colored one and again how there's
an element of Pepper Pot in them
throughout the development
again this is material layout just to
give an indication of the various types
of materials used on the the housing and
the various blocks
you can just identifying where the
emitted areas are for the various types
of development so for example two-story
uh sorry two bed properties
you can see there's quite distribution
there
and this is a street scene
around this various plot we've got the
three
um
sides of the development which are
they've identified on this key here so
at the top along the western edge and to
the southern edge here by these
corresponding
um
scenes here
just again just to show you the
variation
the gaps between the various housing the
variation in Heights and the different
styles of dwellings
um and again we've got some sections
here
through the site along some of the
internal roads and again just showing
the different building types and their
heights and sort of where they're
located
landscape plan you can really General
access and movement plans
so we see the primary vehicle access
proposed principal pedestrian and cycle
routes
I mean this is a generalized key which
covers all the various plots so not all
the elements of the key relates to all
of the individual parcels
and we've got some example of house
types
bedroom bungalows
two bedroom
Bungalows lots of flats
floor plans or flats
two bed dwellings
again just to give a illustration of the
various types of dwellings propose five
bed dwellings
been in cycle store carports
garages
and just some visualizations
again just some photographs
um
from the aerial perspective
we can see an element of the spine Road
here if you have parcel 4 from various
elements there
yeah
again just more photograph showing
what's sort of happening I think the key
one here is this area of view so you can
just clearly see where the various plots
are
um so there's we've got parcel one and
parcel two these were approved precept
previously this is parcel five this is
yet to come forward got the school in
the local Center I've got the spine Road
identified there
and in terms of this application we can
see parcel 4 located over here
um
okay we've got the fear is Frozen just
identifying again where the various
plots are respective to each other local
Center down here
we've got Parcels three six and seven
that's the other application on this
agenda the open space
and the neat neighborhood
um
play area heybridge wood over here and
again just pointing out some of the sort
of Main
areas within the development sites
so
um
I'll just go back to
thank you
thirdly proposed layout and just quickly
run through
some elements of The Proposal but also
in context of the development as a whole
so
um as mentioned earlier this application
proposes 234 dwellings
and again just for context with the
other application which in the large
extent is very similar that the two
applications that members would be
considering today comprise 480 dwellings
um
and then again just to give some further
context with the previously approved
scheme
um
which were 422 dwellings that would mean
with these two applications under
consideration there'd be 902 dwellings
out of the
development approval on the outline
scheme
so although separate residential Parcels
have come forward these are able to be
ready in conjunction with the approved
strategic landscaping and infrastructure
schemes for the various phases of the
development
and I've just pointed these out and
these are all referenced in in the
towards the end of the report
um so
21.00384
2100961 and 2200-289 those are the key
principal Landscaping infrastructure
schemes which have really been approved
and provide the skeleton really to which
all these Parcels are being fitted and
to which they they they would work with
um so so these applications these the
infrastructure and and Landscaping and
those include the various internal main
roads the spine Road Green corridors
Open Spaces Landscaping of the
attenuation basins pedestrian and cycle
networks formal play areas and
allotments so as again emphasized they
provide the context of these various
parcels
so this application follows a similar
form to previous approved schemes in
terms of compliance with the required
parameter plans comprising matters of
land use
green and blue infrastructure access and
movement building Heights and
residential density
in addition there is compliance with
affordable housing quotas of 30 percent
across the development and housing mix
that comply with housing needs
requirements
under Section 5 of the report there is a
section 106 update in respect to the
various legal agreement requirements of
the development and how they are
progressing
and these cover the use of facilities
haybridge wood management plan which has
been approved
the progression of the education
provision early years and primary
secondary school
the local Center medical facilities bus
service agreement local management
organization and the formalized play
areas
electric charging points are better
provided to each new dwelling this is in
accordance with the vehicle parking
standard supplementary planning document
the drainage strategy has already been
approved under the original hybrid
application
5.8 of the report refers to in detail
um of the details approved
under this particular application the
new local flood Authority has no
objections to the drainage strategy such
design and maintenance report
accompanying this application
thank you chairman Mr Johnson thank you
very much indeed I'd like to invite Mr
Carl glossop who's the agent for the
applicant to come up to the table
there's a spare microphone it's a
council fluke review
yeah you go next to Castle stamping
Council of fluka
um Mr glossop you have two minutes
allocated to you for when you start
speaking there'll be a clock come up on
the the screen hopefully in a moment
so you have two minutes
um starting from the time you start
speaking thank you good evening
councilors thanks for the opportunity to
speak tonight as members will be aware
the North haybridge Garden suburb is a
key part of the council's adopted local
plan and is set to deliver a significant
proportion of the council's supply of
new homes in countryside's role as
Master developer we've previously
submitted Reserve matters applications
for the delivery of the Strategic
landscaping and infrastructure which
includes the relief road all the
site-wide drainage and the Strategic
open spaces and play areas which
surround the residential Parcels work is
now well advanced in delivering that
infrastructure in line with the outlying
consent
this application forms part of the third
phase of house building which will start
to fill out the center of the garden
suburb close to the local Center the
scheme in front of you tonight has been
designed in collaboration with the
council's planning and design officers
with comments made both at pre-app and
post submission stages shaping and
influencing the final scheme design the
mix of housing types Accords with the
outline permission with a high
proportion of smaller units as required
and also includes 10 Bungalows slightly
higher than the four percent requirement
from the outlying consent
some members will remember the rather
unpopular Villa units from phase one and
we'll be pleased to hear these units
have been removed from this phase
the scheme will deliver 70 affordable
homes which comprises 30 of the site in
line with policy with a mix meeting the
council's requirements in respect of
tenure and size as well
all of the new homes will meet the
National Space standards and provide
provided with policy compliant levels of
immunity space back-to-back distances
and appropriate parking the scheme
Accords with the parameter plans and
with the Strategic design code endorsed
by the council
officers consider the design to be of a
high quality in line with the
pre-application discussions and
reflecting the aspirations of the
Strategic design code more generally in
light of these factors we hope that
members will be able to support the
officer's recommendation of approval
thank you thank you Mr Blossom thank you
very much thank you councilor stems
okay members we have a recommendation to
approve which is found on page 27 of the
report which is subject conditions
outlined in Section 8 which commences on
page 63. I move this recommendation to
have a secondary thank you councilor
Stevens members open the floor
any comments
thank you councilor Paul dispensely
thank you chair
um yeah so obviously this is reserved
matters and obviously
um
you know it's already got the outline
permission and I hear all this stuff
about design codes but to me that really
didn't look like a garden suburb in the
pictures it doesn't look
um how maybe I'd hope it it did for my
residents living So Close by and it's
not just having a wind but I found out
only yesterday that the primary school
isn't set to come through until 32 till
30 to 33.
um where we'll have all that housing
built out I found out that one of the
parcels already built is more than half
of it looks like it's up for private
rental rather than sale
um I don't know I just wonder if it is
this vision of a garden suburb and I
hope as we move forward to look at our
own local plan that we um think about
carefully about when we use words like
Garden because it doesn't change
anything for the residents there
um that's all I wanted to say thank you
Castle White please
thank you for letting me speak chair um
I've actually been through this and
funny enough it kind of corresponds with
councilor spinsley because I'm looking
at this and for me yes we know we've got
the housing coming but it's the design
now these three-story houses
they all seem to be at the main spine so
again when you come to this main spine
we're trying to create a city effect or
a town effect and I don't know how many
times we've asked these developers to
gradually phase this housing in not not
so it's in your face I'm a town or a
city let's have these great big three
House story buildings as we drive in so
I have a problem with the dime per se
um on 3.1.9 where is that space and how
big is it including the ditches and the
verges that's the first question
um on
3.1.11 where are the green and Open
Spaces because they should be dust
around the development so we're
encouraging people to get out and use
these spaces um but I couldn't actually
find them all I could see was houses
unless it's just poked on one side
somewhere
um on 3.1.27 we've got land use
parameter plan density and garden layout
green spaces again it's the same theme
it's supposed to be a garden suburb it's
supposed to be green where's the green
this looks like you could be in any city
in the country
um and and there isn't the green spacing
out these houses for me the design
should be all about promoting well-being
promoting space promoting that greenness
that we're feigned from We're molding
we're not we're not Basildon or or
Harlow or somewhere we're Malden that's
why we have these Garden suburbs
um moving on from there 3.2.1 it's the
same thing conclusion design quality of
life Green Space is encouraging outside
use well where is it
um on 3.1.34 and 3.1.36 it says focus on
the outer edges linkages and Landscaping
well all I can see is a little bit of
green that will be abandoned around the
outside I mean I for me the designs need
to incorporate all this green within
them there's also no Bridal ways which
we keep asking the Developers for and
they seem to completely ignore those
um and then when I get down the bottom
um 5.15 and 5.16
um it says that well we're not going to
really do anything we're going to do
everything last but what happens is when
you do those things last they don't
happen
um so for me I I think that the I
disagree entirely because the green
spaces and and that that feeling must be
at the foremost for the future residents
so we need to see this linkage now we
need to see these spaces now
um so my problem is not the principle
it's with the design this this looks
like it's Harlow or Basildon or
somewhere this doesn't look like Malden
um so but anyway those questions will be
interesting to point out where all of
that is because like on that drawing
there I can't see it unless you've
abandoned it on the outside edges but
there's nothing in there that says to me
Countryside garden suburb it looks like
a town thank you thank you councilor
white Mr Johnson
several points there I think uh thank
you chairman I'm not sure if I'll be
able to follow all of them directly but
in terms of uh where the development
sits I mean this is a parcel within an
overall scheme I think has been pointed
out earlier the Strategic infrastructure
and Landscaping which envelops all of
these passwords has previously been
approved so
um I I note reference made to maybe on
the outer Regis but largely that's where
the substantive elements of the of the
green infrastructure is is approved the
Strategic Landscaping
um was amongst the very first of the
proposals uh brought forward through
this committee and and the two major
infrastructure applications uh were
approved they contained the substantive
elements within them are the residential
parcels and you know it it it's only
within minutes that one would leave any
any particular front door of any of the
houses and you're within the
um the the the green edges that that
that surround the site
I mean this is a design which is largely
no different from any of those that
we've approved previously
um and and therefore for the sake of
consistency and coherence of the garden
suburb in offices view this is
acceptable and it's in compliance and
follows what members have previously
approved I mean I would say um if there
was a design thought otherwise
um and anything inconsistent with the
parameter plans that have been mentioned
um there would be a particular matter in
that in that in that respect thank you
chairman thank you very much indeed Mr
Johnson Mr councilor Nick Spencer please
thank you chair
um one comment and two questions one the
comment is that one of the three Styles
is uh and this relates to the previous
comment uh Village Edge style which is
approved for the northern boundary so
pleased to see that and let's hope it
remains a village Edge as per policy S4
of the local plan uh then the two
questions one there's a very brief
reference to youth facilities on page 37
it's one and a half lines and we
desperately need youth facilities in the
district I think in the key performance
indicators we looked at a while ago
there were only 13 groups for the whole
district and
um it refers to Long discussions and
eventual approval so I'd like to know
how soon we can expect to see these
proposals and the youth strategy
emerging the other question is about
that one of the conditions on page 65 or
thereabouts it talks about about
planting where trees and hedges do not
Thrive so it's very good you know if
it's more than a tick box exercise it's
great because it says that if within
five years a tree fails to flourish it
will be replaced now to see how this
plays out we only have to look at the
bentyls estate which is the neighboring
estate which has been in place for four
or five years next to Holloway Road and
there's a Boulevard
as you go in which is lined with brown
poles with dead leaves on them and there
are some replacement Hedges which are
brown Twigs sticking out of the ground
so I haven't seen any workers turning up
to replant these uh defunct trees and
plants so is this a tick tick box
exercise if not what is the mechanism
for enforcing that replanting policy
thank you chairman um well the mechanism
would be through a breach of condition
if that is the case
and through the council's enforcement
powers to pursue a replanting
I mean that's that's that that's the
process
so to return to that we can go through
that process for the estate that's
already been built
y application oh sorry councilor Spencer
is correcting me
to break that up and it that's not
applicable on this application no no it
is it isn't so yeah that's fine I I I do
appreciate that but in in context of
obviously the conditions as applied and
and how they're to be managed I can
appreciate the reasoning for the
question so
so I'm happy with it yeah great forecast
especially cassador Darren please
yeah thank you very much I think
actually uh and and I on the back of
what councilor white has said it that
that actual drawing was quite misleading
because it only shows us Mr Johnson has
said that housing parcel it would have
been much more useful to have seen a
complete site plan so we could
understand the relationship of that
housing parcel with the adjacent
facilities green spaces so that we can
we can get an overall look
um I I recall the previous applications
I know that they're there so I think
that it was that was a rather misleading
uh misleading drawing
um and again I have to agree that isn't
doesn't actually
Concord with the original artist
impressions of what a garden suburb
would end up looking like and in fact
all the garden suburbs we went to visit
um on a site visit many many years ago
but that's
maybe but I do understand
um and and that chairman I I do need to
declare an interest on the back of the
comment about Youth Services because
um I'm the cabinet member responsible
for youth services at Essex County
Council okay thank you councilor
any other members care to speak on this
application can't understand please
thank you a chair I'd like to know what
private rented means in and I know what
it means but what does it mean in
relation to this I've never known it be
said that we've got allocated houses and
looks to me to be quite a substantial
number of um can I change my glasses now
I'm sorry private rented on a scheme
where does that coincide with what John
swords always tells us about you know
the affordable housing the makeup what
is required
um I could be wrong again is there only
one five bedroomed house on this site so
we've got all these homes but we've only
got one fed five bedroomed house we all
know that we've got families that are
coming in from war terms or War zones
and everything coming out we're going to
have to house as a Housing Authority we
all know that as District where the
planning authorities that build these
houses and have to house the people who
are much deserving that are coming into
our areas I can't see how we're going to
do that because they're generally larger
families so I would have hoped to see
more than the allocated one and two
bedrooms which at this site seems very
predominantly High to me Mr Johnson and
the other thing about the school I'm
actually very concerned about the
schools because I think new members
maybe don't know but I bang on and bang
on about school delivery delivery
whether it be send or you know ordinary
everyday schools being built and and I
actually sent the information to
councilor uh councilor spencerley
because we've just had a meeting and I
will declare an interest I'm in Essex
County councilor but this this
information is is freely available on
the website you've got there is going to
be a huge deficiency of school places so
you know it does say it's going to be
delivered near the end I think Mr
Johnson correct me if I'm wrong
um but I would I would actually
sincerely ask if the developer along
with Essex County Council can make sure
to deliver it because in my experience
so far some of these schools that have
been promised we're still waiting for
developments they've already been
finished and finally Mr chair for let me
allow Mr Nick Spencer raised an
excellent point
we in Burnham have got Ola because our
houses was front loaded because nobody
listened to us yet again we knew it
would be all finished and now we've got
a deficit
the majority of the sites that have been
planted out are one main one there's
over 20 000 dead trees and bushes and I
totally agree with Mr Johnson because
he's actually been trying to help but
nothing has happened and that site which
was supposed to be a showpiece for one
of the Burnham sites to be delivered is
a disgrace so I actually do think you
need to keep trying your best and
whether that is the process to follow we
all know processes to follow we get told
them every day and I think cancer fluke
has maybe heard them and councilor
Durham and cancer Thompson more than the
rest of us and we get told that process
takes a long time I think we ought to
start to address this when planners are
meeting with the officers to try and
make sure these things are delivered in
an expedient according time that can
actually benefit these communities and
that is not a garden suburb if you want
to see a garden suburb come and look at
the one opposite me at the moment that's
if you don't Grant any more planning
it's beautifully laid out green spaces
play areas and yes I agree Mr cancer
dome's point about you is need to see
the hometown whole thing that's a
massive lot of houses without anywhere
for some little John and Jenny's or
whoever to go and get on a climbing
frame or have a bit of fun looking at a
bug Garden or disabled swings or
whatever you want to put there it's a
huge development and at the moment I
know you know I'm not decided I'm going
to vote but it doesn't inspire me and
I'm sorry if I've offended yeah I really
don't mean to but I do think you can do
better not you personally but developers
can do better for this area we are a
beautiful area and we need to look after
it and stop accepting developments that
could be done better sorry sorry I've
done three minutes you've done five I
have not I have not I'll let you finish
because I think you'll be coming
credentials okay I'll let somebody else
speaking you can finish no no it's fine
German I do as I'm told you know thank
you very much indeed councilor stamp
councilor fluka please
I'll give way to Mr John thank you very
much Mr Johnson yeah
unfortunately I'm I'm not aware of
um the comment that was made by the
counselor in terms of the private
renters I mean the what we've approved
um is um compliance with our with our
housing new standards are set up within
the report
um if there are any other developments
um other than that then that's something
that we would need to look into
but that's a matter that needs to be
brought to our attention
this is a this is the first I've I've
I've heard of this
thank you chairman thank you very much
indeed thank you councilor Fluker please
thank you chairman um
can I just start by reminding all
members chairman there's a very
important meeting in this chamber
tomorrow at one o'clock and I hope that
as many members as possible attend that
um
a question for Mr Johnson through you
Kevin
this is a reserved mess for 234
residential units so it has the
principle of that number already been
agreed
thank you chairman yes it has Jeremy if
you let me come back then so I
understand what members are saying about
layout
um but you know at the end of the day
we're somewhat hold tight because two
three four residential units have been a
gradient principle so we can't change it
we can't add space uh and and chairman
call me an anorak and I counted them but
there's there's only 62 trees on this
site in relation to
234 units but of course you know our own
landscaping experts as a great principle
of this so whilst I understand what
members say
um you know I think chairman you've
you've put the recommendation I'd
certainly support it and and I hope you
now put it to the members so that we can
move on thank you thank you councilor
Fluker I think you've noticed that
there's very few trees but on the
artist's impression there's two people
that live there in one push bike so
again it's something I've always bashed
on about be realistic and let us see
what it actually is um and I know it's
unusual for for the chair to comment but
with the apartments Flats I think the
design is poor I don't think it lends
itself to the concept of what the area
actually is and I'm disappointed to see
them coming in such a bulky in Congress
style but that's a personal thing that
that I feel I need to say
so thank you councilor white please yeah
I think I believe industry has come back
again um obviously I obviously think you
know we we've got um an auction of over
60 trees and we've planted around about
2 000.
um unless you're going to set up a
watering system they will not survive so
unless you we need to put it in the
conditions that they set up an automatic
watering system or they employ somebody
to come out on water every single day
because no trees will survive in a UK
summer it just wouldn't happen doesn't
matter how many plant every single year
they will die unless we happen to have a
wet summer so I think going forward
that's something we need to get written
into the conditions
um I mean there's loads of things you
can do you can have like big bags that
you can fill up they're not very
practical really it wants a proper
irrigation system if you really if the
developers really want to keep these
things alive they're either going to
have to supply a gardener or they're
going to have to do some irrigation
otherwise it's not going to work and
we're going to continually be replacing
them I think you care so right with your
conditions
thank you chairman that doesn't um um
instinctively
sound to me is always a condition which
would meet the necessary legal tests
thank you Mr Johnson
our members we've had a debate and we
have had a proposal which has been
seconded
um so I need to put that to the vote um
by shower hands those in favor please
so we have one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen that's thirteen four those
against please
one two
three and myself is four those abstain
please
so it's one abstention so that's carried
the recommendation there for his past
thank you members
we move on to item seven which is
application two three zero zero two two
six slash r-e-s-m this is land at Broad
Street Green Road and Langford Road and
maypole Road Great totem Essex this is
found on pages 71 to 114. again
obviously Mr Johnson is going to present
in the chamber we do have a public
participant Mr Ben Thomas the agent for
the applicant who'll be invited to speak
uh in a short period of time and I
believe Mr Johnson is also a verbal
update on this item please
thank you chairman um the the verbal
update actually covers both um
applications in terms of Consulting
responses which I've set out previously
um
sorry I need to change the presentation
uh there's normally two of us up here so
apologies
it's okay
thank you
uh to a to a large extent the
presentation on on this application is
very similar to the previous one I will
effectively just be repeating myself
unless members feel I need to go through
those whole points again it's probably
just as well I go straight to the slides
the whole context of the development is
exactly the same that the details are
largely the same just on different plots
um what the developers have had to work
to is exactly the same requirements so I
think probably in that respect I'll just
go straight to the slides and then we
can progress on with the with the
discussion yeah
foreign
so this is the proposed layout for
parcels
three six and and and seven
um this is this this particular uh
element of the development was subject
um some several months ago into a
members update just to up members
briefing
to just sort of take members through the
general principles of what is proposed
and to give some sort of idea
um and obviously this is the this is the
worktop scheme which obviously have been
um progressing with with the applicants
over the last several several several
months
so this proposes uh and I'll just need
to refresh myself with that this
proposes 246 dwellings over these
three Parcels here and to the north of
um Parcels three and and and and and six
is the relief Road uh running along the
top here which is slightly just off um
off the slide
so again very similar to previous we've
got the various story Heights we've got
single story two two and a half and
three stories dotted throughout the
development
I mean we can see a little bit more
context on this one in terms of
something that's your joining
infrastructure which as mentioned
previously and it had been approved by
this committee
again just the affordable housing and
sort of where the and well the various
types of affordable housing shared
ownership affordable rent affordable
housing how they're Peppa dotted
throughout this site
again materials layout this is really
it's probably not going to seem that
coherent from that distance but it's
really just to give an idea that there's
a palette of materials that's applied to
the to the various uh building types
again amenity layout uh private Gardens
uh communal immunity areas balcony areas
communal garden areas these are just the
various types of amenity within the
plots again just
um variously located on on these
different Parcels here
and again we've got the street scene
here
um
the we've got one two three four five
elements of the street scene
um this is a fairly long elevation
um along the northern Frontage
um these the various
um
uh sections here are relate to the
the partitioned areas on the on the top
drawing just to give a flavor of how
when you're walking along that Northern
Edge how the design changes the
variation
Etc
so these are the some these are the
various elements of the sum total along
the top here
and again just showing the Eastern Edge
uh where it joins these attenuation
ponds uh and the sort of Greener
infrastructure
um and again further to the to the east
of that we've got
um immunity areas and beyond that we've
got haybridge wood
again just a bit more of the Street
Scenes I've been just showing the
various house types
and again just showing down the western
edge of the site running through this
sort of internal spine Road along here
and again just another part of the same
stretch of road landscape plan showing
the various Landscaping element we did
have a discussion on the previous
schemes about how that integrated into
the infrastructure surrounding these
various parcels
and just an example of the house types
and floor plans
could always come to bacteria of these
drawings on requests if so required
measure notes
garages
to cycle stores
and again just um some aerial
photographs during the various parcels
we've got three six and seven there just
from the different angles
but again as sort of previously again
this is this is useful in terms of like
seeing where these particularly lie in
terms of other infrastructure
and here we have this parcel seven
parcel six up there and parcel three got
the open space and deep we've got
haybridge wood so it was in terms of
context although it doesn't have the
detailed design I suppose that gives us
the the best context in terms of how the
various Parcels sit together
and um during that presentation thank
you chairman thank you very much indeed
Mr Johnson uh we have one public speaker
as Mr Ben Thomas Mr Thomas
again if you just want to come up to the
table
okay again Mr Thomas would just wait
until the little timer comes up and left
two minutes from the time you start
speaking thank you
thank you Mr Johnson
good evening uh chair members my name is
Ben Thomas and I'm a planning consultant
representing Crest Nicholson Easton who
are the applicant Crest Nicholson is
pleased that this application is
recommended for approval which
represents the culmination of a
significant amount of pre-application
work and positive engagement with your
officers statutory consulties including
Essex County Council and the master
developer Countryside properties
the north haybridge site is a key
development for Crest Nicholson within
its eastern region who have a
long-standing commitment to Malden
District and has been delivering
well-needed homes including affordable
homes and linebrook park and Park Drive
over the last few years
as we've heard this evening Parcels 3 6
and 7 from part of the North haybridge
Garden suburb which is phase four this
phase will deliver the following
benefits the delivery of 246 homes of
which 30 percent will be affordable the
inclusional wide range of accommodation
types and sizes including family homes
Bungalows smaller one bedroom homes
which will assist to create a mixed and
balanced community
increase public access to the Natural
Landscaping environment with a network
of well-planned green spaces and
tree-lined streets has access to the
Woodland Edge which provides a rural
environment for future residents and the
provision of an extensive network of
cycleways and footpaths designed to
encourage sustainable travel and
linkages into the existing town center
community
this Reserve matters application follows
the outline permission granted in 2015
it fully Accords with a site allocation
the local plan the approved strategic
master plan framework and the design
code
there are no objections for any
statutory consulties the design fulfills
that the policy aim of delivering an
attractive new community and the
delivery of high quality housing
including policy provision of full of
Housing and family homes which will
contribute towards the council's housing
targets
therefore in accordance with the office
assessment and positive recommendation
we respectfully request that members
support the application and Grant
planning approval this evening of your
time thank you very much indeed Mr
Thomas
thank you members the recommendations is
to approve and this is found on page 71
of the report and is subject to
conditions outlined in Section 8 which
commence on page 106 do I have a second
thank you councilor Darren has seconded
members open the chamber
Castle White please
thank you Kevin
um well it's pretty much the same as the
last one but my problem is and it shows
you on this picture and if you go back
to the green infrastructure picture
um it's my same old problem with these
green areas the developers come in they
go oh we've got these wonderful green
boundaries you can cycle the children
can walk on that one there the children
can walk on them no they can't you've
got a road one side and you've got an
attenuation pond on the other side
so that because that's attenuation Pond
isn't it the same as the last that was
one of the questions I didn't get
answered on the last application was
location attenuation bonds and if you
look at the slide you're on just now
those attenuation puns are full even
before the housing's built now I know
they'll say oh well we've done our
calculation and studs have signed it off
which yes they have but they're full
already so what's going to happen when
you get the roads in the infrastructure
and where are those children going to go
and play and this is my problem with
these developments all they do is they
think I will love those on the outside
and then we'll lob a bit of green around
the outside but there's no thought
to where people are going to play
because again where are these areas for
play I mean I don't have children but
lots of other people do and so where are
they going to play you know that's my
problem is it's the same old thing and
I'm really surprised that this is
classed as a suitable
design
when you've got all these issues and it
was same as the last one I've just
realized that's the question I didn't
get answer on the last one was the
location of the generation pond so I
think that was the same I think they
were on that corner that development
where you've got the so-called green
areas so um yeah thank you
yeah I think uh apologies for not
picking up on that point but I think um
as I said earlier I mean this these are
just for the residential Parcels the
um
the landscape infrastructure uh play
areas Etc was approved previously on the
um three separate type of applications
um those are the applications that show
all the play areas and and the
infrastructure these attenuation ponds
um I mean we obviously can't go by how
they are now the development hasn't been
approved in this particular respect I
know some other Parcels are but this is
development under construction
um the what I do recall from the
previous infrastructure applications was
that it was stressly multi-use purpose
of these attenuation ponds
um
and you know there was great detail went
into how they would be used and there
was lots of questionings from members at
the time as I as I recall
um but clearly those can't be confused
with this particular application because
that's the structure which has been
improved into which these parcels
um are are to are to relate to so in
terms of how a local residents of these
Parcels relate to the player and
infrastructure that's part of the
infrastructure approval which is a which
has already been considered by members
thank you chairman thank you Mr Johnson
um councilman expense leader please
thank you if you stand to the north of
this whole development you realize just
how steeply it slopes uh to the area of
haybridge which is in flood zone three
to the South nevertheless I'll confine
myself to the plots under discussion and
a detail in 5.8.2 which talks about
um permeable Paving to private driveways
now house owners being what they are uh
you'll get all sorts of drives emerging
in due course I suspect which will be
far from permeable is there such a thing
these days as a restrictive covenant and
does it have any value beyond the paper
that it's written on
okay thank you chairman well the um the
materials are part of
um The Proposal in front of us for
approval there to be submitted details
considered it is fully developed to
carry those
to carry that out and for the materials
to be retained in in perpetuity with the
development it's not for individual
homeowners as you know so we'll come
along and decide that you know they want
you know just um you know tarmac or know
something like that just swayed over
their their front drives or their or
their rear Gardens
I mean that would be a breach of the
planning approval
um or these preserved matters thank you
chairman thank you Mr Johnson
um it's councilor Paul espensi please so
just to clear up for members something
because I've taken a lot of time to go
over there and speak to the developers
so I have quite a good understanding of
how the flood alleviation on this site
will work so those attenuation ponds
will after construction be joined to the
existing ditch Network which is what's
referenced it actually in the report if
you read it
um I've spoken to them about the
modeling for that and actually in a in a
storm event they will make a difference
of less than I think it's a well or
around one millimeter which is a little
disappointing but the reason I bring
this up is obviously it's not
unfortunately it's been approved as you
say I say unfortunately because I do
represent sort of you know hundreds of
homes in flood zone 3A at the bottom of
that but it has been approved and we
have to accept that
um but what it doesn't do and which I do
sometimes get a little bit angry about
is when people say oh it'll take care of
the flood alleviation for haybridge the
developers on there tell me that at the
bottom at Holloway Road it still needs
flood alleviation they openly tell me
that so just so that we have the
understanding for future discussions but
you're right it's already been approved
Mr Johnson I know and uh within the
within the scheme and it is what it is
but that's why they're full is because
once construction is further on they
will connect underground to the existing
they'll drain off to the existing ditch
Network at a controlled rate thank you
thank you
thank you thank you chairman I think
what I what I would say to that is um we
we've approved the scheme which is
modeled in a particular way
um in that these attenuation points
would be delivered and to be multi-use
um within the acceptable limits
um clearly if that's not the case then
that mean that the development hasn't
been carried out
um as approved
so there there would be no obviating
from any responsibility in that respect
I don't know maybe to say well
you know maybe maybe I was going to say
Tim's water yeah
sorry where I live here
um you know it's it's it's a local it's
the water services responsibility we
work with them if they can't deliver
their end of it we can't deliver ours I
think that's something that has an
enforcement we would probably have to
it's probably novel this isn't something
that I have to say personally I've ever
been involved in but to pursue that and
to see how
um obligations can be secured it would
be I it definitely within the remit of
enforcement uh how to how that would pan
out in reality I I don't know yeah
it's not really I think it's probably
not an Enforcement issue it's so let's
get a flood alleviation scheme issue but
I'll leave it there thank you
Spencer councilor stilts please uh thank
you Mr chair on page 89
5.7.1 it says the application site does
not fall within or close proximity to a
nature conservation site however it does
sit right by haybridge Woods which is as
we've said an ancient wood so have we
done any studies on the uh Wildlife that
will be in
the High Bridge Woods that could be
affected like Badges and things like
that by this housing site
Mr Johnson
well thank you chairman I mean the
I mean the
the development itself does not adjoin
heybridge Woods I mean the consideration
for the impact of development on
haybridge where the game was part of the
infrastructure approvals
understand those thank you chairman
thank you
um the next person to speak will be
Council stamp because you haven't spoken
yet thank you
um thank you chair can I actually ask if
the holding objection for Messick's
County Council Suds has been received
and if it has what did has it been has
yeah sorry 7.3 page 104 thank you
councilor white has that been um removed
yes chairman I mean it's what I refer to
in the in the the members verbal update
can I ask why we
why because I'd like to have received to
to read that does it just read that does
it just say it's been removed what what
was the mitigation what is it what has
how has it changed why is it the reason
the reason for the delay is that it
wasn't received until quite late and and
after the publication of the agenda
thank you
councilor whites please you wanted to
come back early on
that's the stamp has raised what I was
going to raise 7.3 about the bloodborne
thoughts so but I mean we really I think
we should have that in writing because I
don't think without that we've got
enough information
um to proceed I mean that's what for
whatever reason it's got held up I have
a concern with that
thank you chairman I mean I mean I
wouldn't have said
um that the objection was removed if it
wasn't this is matters that couldn't be
easily corroborated
um but for the avoidance of doubt I can
actually log into my laptop and I can
actually read out what what they sent to
us if if members would be satisfied with
that approach just have to give me a
second to log in so I don't know if you
want to continue with any other
questions while I do that yeah maybe you
could speak you could circulate that
after the meeting yeah I I do have it
here but it's just a matter of logging
in there now yeah I think I think for
expediency of the meeting I think that
that would um be better off after the
meeting
um yeah it's important that we do
consider information that comes in late
on planning applications
um counselors Paula Spencer you wanted
to come back
um it was just about heybridge wood for
a little bit of clarity just to help out
so only because I know a lot about about
it so
um well quite a lot
um so the woods Woodland is being
managed by the land trust and um there's
currently an application in to um remove
a number of
um trees which actually it will help the
woods it's to um create open pathways
through and raise the canopy and the
wood the the um wildlife in there has
been assessed I have asked for somebody
for another ecologist to have another
look who's interested in moths and
things but I don't actually know if
that'll will happen but there has been a
full ecological assessment in terms of
of what's in there sadly I think there's
only one Badger set now instead of two
what is tragic is that we have lost and
it seems we have lost the red-listed
skylarks
um because the 15 meter buffer zone to
the woods
um skylarks don't generally
um
Nest underneath Woods under trees for
obvious reasons they when they get when
they go upwards get knocked out by trees
I suppose but they're supposed to
supposed to Nestle they do nest in them
Open Fields and it was full of them
there and you probably remember that
initially
um this suburb was opposed by the rspb
but obviously that's all past history so
thank you
yeah thank you I look I think we need to
take uh what Mr Johnson said is verbatim
regarding the holding
um objection from Essex water or whoever
um
an interesting thing about I noticed
that no one's gone on policy D1 and I
actually think the designer some of the
houses looks good and I think you know
with the greatest respect to my friends
from Countryside who sit behind me
um I do think that the quest Nicholson
development in Park Drive if it is part
Drive I think is one of the best ones
actually that's come into Malden over
the years
um but one thing about this one thing
about this application which chairman I
don't have any problems with
um is that if you actually uh agree this
recommendation tonight you will actually
be agreeing to 246.
black front doors
um which I find so I'm sure you all
picked up on that uh and I I think
there's I think you know I'm surprised I
I know the police will have been
consulted over this application because
they always are and but it does surprise
me if if a suspect makes good and he
runs onto this hm and says and the
witness says he ran into the house with
the black door but I I I I sort of a a
admire the design palette of Chris
Nicholson's over this Gemini I know
you've put I know that you've put the uh
the recommendation and I think what
councilor dispensely says about and the
birds and everything else you know that
would have been mitigated by the ecology
report so Gemini I can't see any reason
why we can't approve this and and
hopefully I'll be able to put that now
and we can vote on it thank you thank
you councilor fluka I'll certainly do
that after I've exhausted any member who
wishes to raise any comments on such
important matters
um I'd say the chamber as it seems to
reach a conclusion so we have a
recommendation that has been seconded
members could I ask for a show of hands
for the recommendation please
your hands up quite High because I'm my
eyesight's getting terrible one two
three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen fourteen four those against
please
one two three those abstain
I'll abstain so that's carried please
thank you very much indeed members for a
very informative and caring debate we
move on to item number a any other items
of business that the chairman deciser
urgent there is one and that's just to
reinforce what councilor Fluker has said
about our meeting tomorrow at 1pm
members okay uh therefore I bring the
meeting to a close so thank you for your
contributions this evening I now draw
this meeting to a close at 8 30 p.m
thank you as the meeting's now closed